hello everyone how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing fine looks like I'm
not sick I think I am NOT got a little
raspy throat but other than that I think
I'm okay I hope you are just as well as
good as I am one more time like to
notify people that we've uploaded a book
and you can go to this site raw
hypothesis calm and if you click on
books you'll find that there's a book
that you can download there for free and
it'll bring you up to speed on the rope
model of light which is one of the
things that we talk about here okay and
for those of you who have a second
language you can contact us at toca
Kukai at hotmail.com if you want to
translate the book to your native
language okay okay so how is everyone
doing out there with coronavirus I guess
you're most people are stuck in the
world are stuck within their homes right
now and here in heaven we had a little
accident we had a fellow his ease the
economic Minister of Hessen of the
province or the state of Hessen and he
committed suicide
yeah he's the Minister of economics I
think he was and so that doesn't bode
well for for what's coming for what I'm
suggesting is gonna be the extinction of
man I don't know how long it's gonna
last you know maybe this is the
beginning maybe it's years away who
knows all I can give you not as a
timetable what I can give you as a
mechanism that's what I do here okay
mechanism of extinction is through
economics no doubt about in my mind at
least and yeah here you have what some
cities around the world look like this
is Norwich and Tina born as artists we
were there last time for the conference
about a block from that building on the
right
though we write the Abasto ball and we
were a block away from there you can see
it's empty
usually this has gazillions of people
and it's the same street at night
farther down on the other side of well
far away some about a mile away over
here the upper left and you can see at
night and they it's completely empty and
this street known as Avenue known as
guardian 'this is a is known as the
street that never sleeps oh well now
it's sleepy and you'll see this
everywhere I mean New York even here in
Frankfurt in general you know they
haven't imposed a curfew yet over here
it's voluntary but since people are
pretty much staying at home it's like
they're not gonna need to enforce
anything here yet you know at least it
seems that way but in a barrio in the
south oh yeah they've got the Gestapo
stopping you and they've got the chutes
stuff for the whole the whole work
though all the police is on the on the
beat this is in India they're doing fine
you know they're practicing for the
cricket championship you know using
people as as sparring partners and they
do a lot of exercises over there getting
to be healthy people and that's pretty
good it's good for the country I guess
right
everybody's doing exercise over there so
yeah I guess this brings new new
behaviors and there's going to be lots
of new behaviors you know you're gonna
have a lot of the companies like you
know you have a company like Amazon
which is a bee a moth you know
gigantic company and they're probably
gonna turn out to be ok with this
because a lot of people are going to be
ordering stuff through the internet and
they're just going to get more used to
that
and that might have an effect not you
know just shopping you know people will
not go out so much to do shopping don't
do all the shopping or more of it
through the internet and you know that's
got to cause a lot of unemployment
that's what I can tell you okay so yeah
there's gotta be changes in the next few
months and it's gonna be quite
interesting to see what kind of changes
the politicians impose right among them
the fact that they're giving money out
and they're giving tons of money out and
that's also gonna lower the real value
of the salaries of people who work and
so you got to keep all that in mind and
there's going to be a big impact in the
next few months who knows if we come out
of it they say three months maybe maybe
even up to the year you know the last
depression lasted ten years until the
war got us out of it and a war is not
gonna get us out of this one because you
know the only thing a war can do is
stimulate manufacturing it cannot
stimulate services so a war would not
help us in this case yeah just keep all
that in mind as well all the jobs are in
services and those are vanishing you
know by the minute there's what 3.3
million people in the United States that
already asked for unemployment that's
got to have a big impact anyways let's
get on with the subject matter of today
we had had a comment by a gentleman who
came over and he says scientific
community international we would love to
have you to join us please read our
description about us and that's in
Facebook so I went over there and find
out okay who are these people what do
they do and this is what I found
okay yeah atheist scientific community
international the science community
international SEI goes beyond
atheism uh-huh the meaning of Sciences
knowledge uh-huh SCI ology I thought it
was sociology there was misspelled no
it's psychologists yes I ology I guess
it's pronounced a scientific philosophy
of life an intellectual
search for knowledge and rationality and
at the bottom you know I looked it up
and said the person who believes more in
science and technology rather than God
these people are inclined towards the
logical reasoning and deducing events
rather than believing in destiny okay we
are psychologists people who view the
world from a scientific perspective
hence we use logical deductive reasoning
that there is a logical explanation for
everything okay our aspiration is to use
science and technology to help people
reach the fulfillment of their lives
okay well I have doubt that these people
are scientists and what gives them away
is that first word atheists you know
atheists are not scientists they're
religious fanatics and you might say
well bill maybe you're a Christian or a
closeted Christian or Buddhist or
whatever no no I was an atheist for most
of my life okay I got out of atheism and
got not into theá-- ism not into
agnosticism now I got into something
called science and science does away
with all three of these and yeah I've
got a long record with atheism and
communism I was a communist for many
years was an atheist for many years I
abandoned both philosophies both ways of
thinking and you know when I was a about
13 14 years old I was living in
Baltimore Maryland
we were living over there with my family
and we met
Madalyn Murray O'Hair and she was the
founder of American Atheists okay and we
were among the first people who joined
American Atheists we were almost the
founding fathers of American Atheists
my folks were okay and Madeline came to
our house a couple times and you know it
turns out that many years later you know
I was in Austin and Advanced Micro
Devices my company sent me
in Texas they transferred me to do some
more spying and while I was there one
day I decided to figure out if there was
you know an American atheist branch in
Austin Texas and it turns out that there
was and it was Madeline herself and so
about 20-25 years later I I went and to
the American Atheists and found these
folks you know that's Madeline and her
daughter Robin who was really adopted
she was really the daughter of her son
so she was her granddaughter she adopted
her as her daughter and that's John her
son her second son her first one was
William the father of Robin and I went
there I went there and then I met
Madeline 20 25 years after I had met her
for the first time and I told her that
you know my father's had contributed to
her struggle she went in there and she
got a card she says I kept the card from
everyone who ever donated money to my
cause that she got a card and it had my
father's signature on it and that was
the last time I saw Madeline a few years
later she was kidnapped together with
the other two and they were murdered and
that's a tragic but interesting story
you can find some of it in the Forensic
Files there episode 10 of season 7 and
yeah it's a very tragic story but it's
an interesting one you know what kind of
lives they they ended up living you know
it's just interesting the way I see it
there is no difference between an
atheist a theist and an agnostic okay
though these people belong to religion
why okay let's find out why some people
don't want to hear it because they say
oh honey an atheist I'm a rational
person and everyone else is not and so
they don't want to hear the arguments
and they just do themselves a disfavor
you don't have to agree but it be nice
to know where the punches are coming
from you know
when you're gonna go up in the ring so
it's nice to prepare and know the other
side okay what objections other people
have and Athiya in general I summarized
this there's all variants and nuances
here okay but this is just a summary I
believe that God exists that's
essentially the way of thinking of
theists
the atheist says I know I don't believe
or whatever he'll phrase it in a million
different ways and defend each one to
say that's not believe and they'll go
all over this stuff essentially that's
that's what they say I know that God
does not exist yeah the guy feels that
there is no God out there okay that's
that's their position an agnostic wants
some kind of proof he says well I'm not
convinced yet I don't have proof yet
that God exists you know blah blah blah
what is the scientists a real scientist
says let us assume that God exists
that's got to do with a scientific
method that we started at the beginning
of this century okay so we have a new
paradigm and we do not respect the
scientific so-called scientific method
the religious method that we've been
doing for the last 400 years since the
17th century so called scientific
revolution now that was not a revolution
that was or maybe it was but they didn't
pursue they they weren't scientists okay
a scientist is someone who explains and
these people did not explain they went
on a tangent and they did math and math
can only describe and all we have today
is a bunch of descriptions and
irrational explanations and that's
because of the so called scientific
method that all these mathematicians are
called mathematicians have followed okay
now irrational scientists let us assume
that God is as God can only be an
assumption God cannot be a theory God
cannot be an explanation God can only be
an assumption and you say well let's
assume that God exists and now I'm gonna
explain how the universe came to be you
know here's this guy with a magic wand
he goes abracadabra he makes the world
okay fine you know he can go on with a
theory but the point is
God cannot be a theory in himself God is
just an object that you're going to use
to to found your theory upon pay your
explanation upon okay and yeah and
whether God exists or not has nothing to
do with proving with eyes with ears with
touching now we don't prove the
existence of a chair by touching it okay
and the way we we prove to this by
defining we define okay we define what
exists means that no one in the last
10,000 years define the word exist in a
rational manner that's the whole problem
that's why atheists and theists run
around in circles because no one defined
the word exists and once you defined the
word existed all religions died
including atheism and yeah exist is
physical presence physical requires an
object presence requires location God if
God wants to exist he not only has to be
an object he cannot be loved he cannot
be grace he cannot be intelligence those
two concepts know God has to be an
object God has to have shape and that's
not enough yeah squares have shape but
they don't exist
Superman has shape he doesn't exist and
so God in addition has to have location
there's got to be a distance between my
chest in his then God exists by
definition not because I believe
disbelieve or because it hasn't been
proven or because I proved it or
whatever
now it's by definition things exist by
definition you just have to define the
word exist and we're done then we know
what exists and what doesn't
or like I like to say if you want to
know if God exists or not define the
word exists then you'll know if God
exists very simple okay
what's I got to do with it's got to do
with the scientific method here it is in
a nutshell okay and you can see it's a
little different than the nonsense
followed by the mathematical physicist
so-called physicists they have a
different version of science
and we have no use for their version of
science it's not science because they
ended up with all irrational
explanations for how this universe works
they cannot explain a single phenomena
out there out there in the in in space
and down here on earth they cannot
explain anything at the micro level at
the macro level they cannot explain
gravity why the earth doesn't fly out of
the Sun they cannot tell you that they
said well it's the warpage of space-time
you know you got the Sun weighing down
the canvas and forming this depression
and the earth runs around it like the
little ball around the roulette and
that's why the earth doesn't fly out
yeah but it turns out that space-time is
a concept of mathematical concept is
that what you bent is that the
depression is in a concept so we got a
big problem with a so called Rash
irrational that's what they are the
physical interpretations that
mathematical physics offers okay yeah so
we have three steps the step one because
we're going to try to explain that's
what science is about explaining a
theory rush and lead to someone else
okay a mechanism in the case of physics
and so we need the object what objects
are gonna be the actors in your theory
we need to know have precise definitions
especially over the words such as object
and exist those two emotion things of
that nature words of that nature and
then the initial scene you need to have
a starting point
every film because you got to make a
film of your theater you should be able
to make a film of a physical theory
about physical interpretation and if
you're gonna make a film you better put
objects there something with shape I
need to see something what do you got to
put energy in there what's energy oh
what shape does energy have what what
shape does a field have what shape does
a wave have if these are all concepts
dynamic concepts in fact so now you need
the initial scene you need to have the
first few frames of the film so that you
have your starting point for your theory
okay and then the theory are the
mechanisms and causes that's in a
nutshell the most important part okay so
yeah we have a different way of doing
science here that's why it's called
rational science we are
we are only interested in rational
explanations for how the universe works
we want to know how the invisible stuff
especially works how does gravity work
how does magnetism work how does
electricity work this is what we're
interested in and these people have no
explanations for that and that shows the
failure of the so-called Newtonian or
Galilean scientific method they're no
good experiments math no use for them
what we need is explanations we need
mechanism won't we see the mechanism we
understand don't give me any math we
don't need any math not to understand
how mother nature runs her shop ok ok so
let's put this thing back up here so
that we can compare them side-by-side
this is what this group does and this is
what we do or what the objections we
have now atheism is part of religion we
have no use for atheism knowledge now is
this part of religion we have no use
whatsoever for knowledge now this means
that you already swallowed something you
swallowed the kool-aid you already know
no one can change your mind and that's
not what we do in science the science we
explain so that you understand the
mechanism just by watching a movie you
know you want to know how pulley works
well you got a rope tied around a pulley
and lifting a box you pull out the rope
in the box goes up now you understood
just by watching the film and that's
that's got nothing to do at all to do
with knowledge rationality well people
have to define rational and people have
to define what an explanation is have
these people define these terms I don't
know I I doubt they have so what we do
yeah we we do define these terms in here
they are ok we have an explanation the
cause in the case of physics reasons
philosophy underlying a phenomena that's
what it is you need to in the case of
physics you need to have a mechanism of
how it happened and explanation deals
exclusively with the past science deals
only with consummated events ok
description that's what math does is a
listing of physical properties
of a physical object okay that's all it
is and they use adjectives to describe
that's what but of course you won't see
that in mathematics because what
mathematics does is it works with motion
things in motion so that their
descriptions have to do with phenomena
that happened and what they're doing is
describing speedway DeMille's kinds of
things okay and the last one help people
technology now we we say that we're the
last humans on earth
okay so we're the last generation of
humans on earth so now don't help people
because in the sense that I mean of
course you're gonna help people but you
know there's no long-term solution for
humans were the last branch not
everybody agrees with that okay and you
need to be come from in your eyes with a
theory again not with when that's
astrology we need to know we need to
understand okay what the mechanism what
the mechanism is how did the dinosaurs
die how didn't and earth all died that's
what we need to figure out and none of
these people have figured it out you got
all these geneticist saying that they
made it with us and that's how the diet
at the the never thaws disappeared and
the dinosaur well there was a rock that
fell on earth and just killed them you
know and so on and so forth all nonsense
absolute nonsense so yeah we need to
figure out how these PASOK's extinctions
occurred and then extrapolate them to
man and when you do that well though we
have very little chance of surviving
what's coming up in the next few months
okay
rationality what is rationality well we
have criteria for that as well so we put
it down to primarily as that first one
and when someone treats a concept as an
object then they're real find ur doing
concretization and when they do that
it's quite irrational okay that's the
criteria the primary criteria you have a
couple more using undefined terms or or
using them inconsistently
and that the theory doesn't follow from
the assumptions describing and thinking
that you've explained a lot a lot going
on in in mathematical physics and then
the mechanism proposed doesn't work or
cannot be imagined you know space time
again because it's a concept so you
cannot even imagine the mechanism big
because it's not visualizable you know
you cannot visualize this thing okay
squaring the circle there are poor Oh
God trying to square the circle okay so
so I don't know about these folks who
say they're doing science okay they
should become acquainted with this site
first a little more so they realize that
they're gonna crash against a brick wall
here there's gonna be and I make no
apologies I try to be as honest as
possible you may not like what I say but
I'm gonna give you a different
interpretation what you see out there
okay you don't have to buy it it's up to
you you know all I'm saying is before
you can come and talk about what the
what science is saying well I I don't do
religion I do science you may be doing
religion also especially if you do
mathematical physics that's your
religion just nonsense okay here's
another fellow he put a comment okay see
if we can move along here
they say the electron orbit is a
probability way without any certain
point in location nor directions so when
light enters our into a prism there
becomes some interference patterns which
slow down the speed of light yeah that's
the version of quantum mechanics but I
want to address that first statement the
fact that these people say it's a
probability wave okay so what is a
probability wave let's find out okay
here we have it definition you'll find
out their probability waving quantum
state of a particle particle ha ha ha
I guess they referred to a corpuscle
right or system as characterized by a
wave anyway what's a wave there's no
physical object called away wave is a
verb propagating through space through
space we don't travel through space we
travel to the moon
you can't travel through space because
space is not a medium space is not a
physical object space is not a container
but yet all these people treat space as
being made of particles or being some
kind of container contains the ether who
knows what space time you know you got
all these notions of space and none of
them they what they never did is defined
a word nothing that's the problem
they can't define the word nothing and
that's why they Spade made space into
something in which square the magnitude
of the wave at any given point
corresponds to the probability of
finding the particle at that point okay
again what is a wave it's a disturbance
that's not a physical object so we can't
say that a wave did this or the wave did
that it's not a noun it's a verb
particle it's an excited field again not
a noun
field is not a is a concept and the
concept is not a physical object what is
a field of physical quantity okay so we
have quantities okay let's see what this
is here we have a field let us see if
you like my field
it's the field is a bunch of numbers
that are vibrating big nine because you
know it goes from the center outwards
the farther away you go from the center
of an object the weaker is the field
whether its gravitational electric or
magnetic so is that what it is a bunch
of numbers that are vibrating is that
what a field is and and here's a better
image this this comes from these folks
okay
these are here you have a vector field
okay and you have an electric field you
got all these fields that these people
talk about okay is this is this what
we're gonna is are these the fields that
these folks are talking about yeah so so
you got to keep in mind that they're
talking about concepts see what you're
staring at all those in Janeiro's that
you see they're everywhere you see all
those arrows those are vectors so what
they have is they they made a physical
object out of a mathematical concept
called the vector they just put a bunch
of vectors and they start moving them
around you think they're moving
something physical and they're not what
they're moving is is number lines and
people are not aware of that because
we're so used to seeing all these things
that we take them for granted that oh
okay yeah I see what it is yes it's a
wave so what is a wave
oh it was a bunch of vectors and people
not very much aware of that and that's
that's the problem okay
so you know I try to wise people up on
these things because they don't realize
what what the mathematicians are doing
they're tough they're they're dealing
only with concepts with abstract
concepts introducing them as physical
objects that's the problem we'll see a
couple more here in a minute
what does Wolfram say for for this
probability way well it says it's the
probability of finding an electron
within the volume of an atom okay so so
what are we talking about we're just
saying that that that's what moved a
probability wave is that the explanation
is that the physical interpretation so
yeah you you have to look at the
language you have to look at what these
people are trying to tell you and you'll
never understand them they you wouldn't
admit that they don't understand their
own theories and right yeah they never
will because this is the nonsense that
they put forward they say well you know
it's a probability wave that's moving
what that hell is a probability wave is
it a physical object I mean what is it
made of water or what you know okay
here's another comment along the same
lines okay and this thought says a wave
is energy propagating through a medium
for example the displacement of water by
a stone striking upon well a wave can't
be energy because neither waving our
energy our physical objects and this is
the problem people are talking in in in
we're using word wizardry that's what
they're using there they're moving cogs
and they think they're moving an object
is your well a wave is an energy well we
don't know what an energy is and let
alone a wave so so far we have nothing
we have console all you said is that
intelligence is the movement of love
now what sense does that make and that's
what this is saying here to say that a
wave is energy in motion is the same
thing as saying that intelligence is
love in motion you haven't said anything
that's okay for poetry by the way you
know but you know and here you have a
picture of energy okay so he keep a good
eye on it there you have positive energy
and negative energy okay so if you ever
wanted to know what energy looks like
well there you have it okay and yeah and
it turns into particles which is empty
space supposedly that's that's the
version of of quantum mechanics okay
here's a fine man who puts you straight
if you missed something okay he says you
know he Nobel Prize by the way it is
important to realize that in physics
today we have no knowledge of what
energy is yeah whenever they don't
understand something they say oh energy
and everybody says haha now I understand
and so that's that's what that's the
world we have today so yeah these people
these people are not there they don't
understand their own theories because
they're using word wizardry to get by
they're saying energy force-field time
the charge you know I have all these
fancy words and they're all concepts and
they want to do physics physical
interpretations with concepts yeah and
so here you have you know the spirit
that we used to have in the old days and
now they call it energy yeah and so so
now you know what energy is it's just a
rehashing of the old spirit of
traditional religions right okay another
comment so we get through the comments
here and this fellow says I was taught
that color was a fun
in a wavelength and yeah it is I mean if
we're gonna use the wave the longer the
wave the redder is the shorter the wave
the bluer it is so here you have it it's
in the spectrum okay you can see the
spectrum is based the color spectrum is
based on wavelength and also on
frequency okay and they're inversely
proportional okay and you know the
reason they're inversely proportional as
you see it here okay this is the
equation C equals frequency times
wavelength when wavelength goes up then
what happens to frequency
well it goes down they're both inversely
proportional okay and so ya wavelength
is a color as a function of wavelength
the problem is that that's not what the
quantum people believe they say that on
one side when they're talking about one
thing and then they say something else
on another this is what you should be
able to see through a prism you should
see colors coming out the colors you
even see through the prism but also when
they come out and and these people don't
don't say that they say that look when
it's going through the prism light slow
the the wavelength slows down it slows
down and what's slowing down is the
speed they say and the speed is not
wavelength and wavelength is not speed
so keep that in mind you you you can't
have it both ways you either talk about
speed or you talk about wavelength and
these people have these weird notion see
here's here's one which I'm saying that
that their theory predicts which is if
if you have this prism out there in
outer space okay and you shine a white
light in you'll get the rainbow colors
in the prism but then since when it
comes out there's nothing to stop it
again it should go back to white light
and that's not what you get what you get
is what you just saw you get something
like this okay and the other thing about
this is that they get in
verse they have violet light or
ultraviolet right for example that end
of the spectrum and it's got shorter
wavelength but travel slower when we
know that it's higher energy and red
light or infrared has the opposite
effect according to quantum mechanics
they say look it's a longer wavelength
but it travels faster through the prism
this is this is their conclusion even
though red light has lower energy as
they call it right then violet light so
they have a contradictions everywhere
and they never clarify these things they
just get away with it with saying these
things and that's it okay
just in case the rope model there it is
rope model of light why we have colors
very straightforward
you have the red atom there yellow atom
and the blue or purple atom at the
bottom and you can see the red one
pumps slower than the blue one right and
what happens is the wavelength in other
words the link length in case of the
rope model is longer and that atom is
tied to another atom down to row that's
beyond the edges of the frame there okay
and so it's pumping that frequency and
that wavelength to that atom that's down
the road could be one in the air okay
and that's that's essentially how it
works
so it's straightforward with with the
rope model okay there's no mystery there
whatsoever okay what I want to talk
about today specifically were a subject
that I left behind quite a bit about a
month ago at least and that's bringing
back the Greeks okay I want to establish
where we got some of the geometry that
we have today especially point line in
plane and hopefully I get to the plane
today okay but anyway let me rehash some
of this here we have Google Airy and
he's the guy who came up with this
notion of that which has no parts for
for the word point
and he states also this is out of his
book okay bye by the way physics can
have no extremity the extremity and the
thing of which it is the extremity being
distinct in other words the points at
the end of a line says are distinct than
the line okay and we're going to see
this notion also in Euclid's elements
okay he uses these notions he says the
point is that which has no parts and
he's at the ends of a line are points
okay so that all the Greeks around this
time we're thinking in the same terms
and I'm sure this is not original from
you cliff because Euclid was born the
generation after Aristotle maybe two
generations away we don't really know
when Euclid was born
okay so Euclid studied in Athens and he
probably studied in the other school in
Plato's school with people who did not
agree totally with Aristotle but they
all pretty much had these ideas about
what a point is and the definitions and
so on and the fact that points are the
ends of a line okay
and they use it for different purposes
Aristotle is gonna be talking about
foundations of physics or what he wants
to he once explained the natural world
he wants to explain how this universe
works so he uses these nouns that you'll
see in his book he talked about location
distance actually distance traveled
because that's all that math ever did
motion time uses number also he uses
number he tries to use numbers to make
his case okay
and Euclid uses something else you know
he uses other types of nouns because
he's gonna set the foundations for
mathematics or geometry
he used the point the line the plane
things you know Aristotle stopped at
lying because that's all he needed he
didn't need the plane he didn't need the
solid and he did use the number because
he's gonna use that as locations along
his distances and separations
essentially okay
so they come from two different sides
you clip from Aristotle they they were
trying to accomplish two different
things
okay and so how does Euclid define lying
okay well he defines it as breathless
length okay and we got a problem and
right there and then whether it's the
translator or whether it was Euclid
himself I don't know because it's very
hard unless some Greek knows exactly
what that word means you know breathless
breath is a vector it's not a dimension
and and so what this person is saying
that you have this length that extra
extends I guess forever but it has no
thickness that's that's the that's the
breathless part I guess that they're
trying to convey so what so what is a
line I'm you know what do we have in
front of us specifically how is this
related to geometry because geometry
deals with shapes primarily you know
first and foremost you need to have a
shape and not only do we have no shape
for the no part point but we have no
shape for the so called one-dimensional
line and I challenge you you know grab a
pencil a chalk crayon whatever you need
I want you to draw one dimensional
anything okay anything I don't care you
these guys say it's a line fine card a
line I want you to to scribble the right
to draw a1 illustrate a one-dimensional
anything see and that's what you get in
math you get a lot of these things like
singularities that have no size no
volume no nothing it's a zero that
mention all nothing and they call it a
singularity and that's what the black
hole is gonna be and something similar
with a line you know I
you've got the string theory and they
use lines and what is the line well you
know they have these what dimensional
lines and that's what they're gonna
construct their theory
keep that in mind that string theory
that's the new kid in town you know
anyways the ends of lines are points
parallel very interesting issue there
because he says parallel straight lines
are straight lines straight lines which
are straight lines great which being the
same plane and being produced
indefinitely meaning infinitely writing
stand them all the way to can kingdom
come right in both directions do not
meet one another in either direction and
that's essentially the definition we
have today so what is Euclid saying that
I gotta go all the way to infinity to
find out if these two lines are parallel
I have to run an experiment I have to
walk or run maybe you know take a bike
or a car or an airplane good at the end
of infinity to find out if these two
lines are parallel so so we got a
problem because this is not a definition
this is a proof disguised as a
definition and this is the one that
people that geometers are still using
today so no parallel lines are
equidistant lines throughout the length
officio of the short one you think
you'll get it here let me put it up here
yeah that's that's the definition of a
parallel line whether they like it or
not that's what it means in physics it
means that two lines are equidistant
they have the same distance throughout
what you have in front of you because
there are no infinite lines in physics
only in mathematics in and so-called
geometry these people have infinite
lines in physics there are no infinite
lines first and second what you have is
really edges of the lines because the
lines are really two-dimensional okay so
we don't know of any one dimensional
line but whoever knows of one should
just bring it in or draw it or whatever
okay
okay here's a the definition of line
continued what you have is again he says
its breathless length and in proposition
30 12 of his
elements he reinforces this notion by
extending the line infinitely he says to
draw a straight line perpendicular to a
given infinite straight line and the
problem with the infinite straight lines
is that he uses that throughout his book
and again this is all from the Greeks
right and you'll see that they'll extend
any line like the line that forms the
edge of that triangle you know they'll
extend it because they're gonna figure
out some angles from the outside of the
triangle and in order to do so they have
to extend the line and that's where the
so-called infinite line or the fact that
a line segment is not a line comes in
you know that notion they have to extend
the line in order to figure out angles
okay and yeah as you can see the line is
two-dimensional I don't know of any a
one-dimensional line but again if any of
you know one I sure would like to see a
one-dimensional line never saw one yeah
let me know and well he moves on to
planes okay
planes he calls them or whoever it may
be it's a translator you know I don't
want to choose you CLE completely here
okay but he says a surface that which
has length and breadth only he's talking
about a plane okay so should be a plane
is that which has length and breadth
only okay and again it's not breath
because they're pitting a dimension
length against a vector which is breath
okay the three vectors for purposes of
physics which you would think that's
what geometry was trying to figure out
here the three vectors are depth breadth
and elevation because they're all motion
you're moving a vector is a dynamic
concept okay on the other hand dimension
is a static one you know you just have
three perpendicular lines to each other
at 90 degrees okay there's no motion in
dimensions but there is motion in it
vectors and so these people whoever
whether it was Euclid or translate or
someone goof
because you cannot pit lengths against
breath and that's where you get also
these people pitting you know space
again time they put it an arrow going up
for time and we'll get to that when I
get to dimensions but you can see what's
happening here
okay he says the edges of surfaces are
lie of a surface are lines and a plane
surface is a surface which lies evenly
with the straight lines on itself
exactly what the difference between the
first definition number five there in
definition seven I have no idea I've
looked it up I still can't figure out
what the differences are okay but let's
look at the summary that I have against
all this okay I'll put it next to it
here okay these are the objections I
have to
Euclid's notions first the surface is 3d
the word surface does not belong in in a
2d world of planes surface is 3d plane
it is 2d and that's why that word
surface is wrong in his definition 5 and
again I don't know if it's him or the
translator breath is a vector not a
dimension you cannot put you know you
cannot pit breath against the length or
width or height edges are not lines okay
that's a long story I'm not gonna go
over that right now lines are 2d okay if
you know a line that is 1d let me know
ok and brought it and then send it to me
I'll publish it they'll eat my words a
plane is that made of lines or points
because if it were made of lines and
points it would not be smooth a plane is
made of a single piece and it's usually
a piece of it's a piece of a solid
square is one side of a cube that's the
notion of plane okay and you see it
head-on so it's got to be a perfect
square soon as you tilt the cue you no
longer have a square I mean if you could
get a perfect cube right an ideal cube
right God's cube yeah
and you tilt it a little bit now you got
a rectangle you no longer have a square
you say no from another angle now you
have a square all we have is width is
the field of view so you can't tilt
these things if you tilt the circle you
get an oval and so on and these people
just tilt squares and ovals and just
brought on a without bothering you know
and then the issue is how flat is flat
and you might say well how important is
that I mean yeah flatness is you know
flat is flat like a flat table now then
that's not flat tables are not flat okay
flat is if we're gonna use the word
consistently we have to define it very
precisely okay and flat means no
thickness okay let me show you an
example here here you have the Flat
Earth Society I guess some of you heard
of that right and one fellow there at
the flatter of this flatter because
they're several Flat Earth Society and
one denies the other guy right so this
model states that there is an infinite
plane of exotic matter somewhere below
the disc pushing in the opposite manner
of traditional gravity this is a recent
theory and is in progress they have this
um this plane I drew it white guy and it
just cuts the universe in half and it's
infinite right and so that means you
can't see below this plane okay so the
earth sits on this plane I guess you
know in this flat plane and so yeah you
can't see below it and so the question
is how do you know there's a plane there
first and how do you know it's it's flat
well how flat is the earth if these guys
talk about the Flat Earth Society how
flat is flat have they ever defined the
word flat or are they gonna use some
some you know very loose notion for
flatness okay so now you got to define
the word flat perfectly exactly if you
got to be the Flat Earth Society okay
and one thing they don't define is the
word flat and we don't need to define it
mathematically either we needed
qualitative we need to
you find it qualitatively okay because
we're going to talk about how the earth
is made right and so it's it's a
qualitative issue you can't go in there
and say whether it's a zero whatever no
yeah you can say zero thickness that's
about it but if you get zero thickness
you got nothing and so zero thickness
means nothing that's what it means okay
so keep that in mind you can't define it
as zero thickness okay you think the
flat earthers are the only ones who have
problems though here you have the
relative this okay and what do they do
well they have this quantum dr. quantum
he goes to flatland and you can see she
sticks his finger through flatland and
it's not flat it's it's got a certain
thickness so again how flat is flat I
mean if if quantum dr. quantum can stick
his finger through through the thickness
of flatland well it's the flatland is
not so flat okay and again so these
people have problem with that you might
say well how important is that well it
turns out that you know they they moved
on from Abbott's flatland which was a
20th century book 19th century book and
today we're talking about not the flat
earth but the flat universe this is what
the relative is say we have a flat
universe and here you have the bottom
pictures from them the upper one on the
right is mine but essentially mimics
what they're saying here we got this
w map study and they say that's our
universe well put it on a disk because
they're saying is supposed to be flat so
we have this roundish or spherical flat
universe whatever you however you
interpret that of a spherical flat okay
yeah and it doesn't stop there you can
see this these are the images that
you'll see here and there you see this
is the block universe and a
cross-section of that is tying and so
the our flat universe sits on that flat
you know it's like the cover of that cup
horizontal cup okay so it's so yeah
they're thinking about a flat universe
of
kind who knows how are they picture then
they never draw it and here you have a
picture of it from astronomy magazine
okay and this was a I think what is it
1999 yeah and again you can see this
this what they draw this is the universe
they're proposing and you're saying what
do you mean are they really saying us
these these these great scientists these
sages yeah that's what they're saying
here the any signs flat universe here it
is look I showed you from the magazine
that's that's good ol Steven Gorky
okay and this is the university proposes
the one in the center okay so yeah that
was printed in a magazine this is the
universe they proposed so you live in a
flat you know forget about the Flat
Earth Society here these guys are the
flat universe Society and that all comes
from Aristotle and and Euclid when they
defined these terms for the purposes of
geometry remember relativity proposes
that gravity is the geometry of space
and it's curved in our world in the
four-dimensional world in slide so you
try to understand that and see if you
can make sense of it and you know when
you put them against the wall they say
what you got to take math to understand
it so so we need to take under the
mother nature needs done to take math to
understand her own universe
think about that anyways I'm gonna
continue with this and dimensions
especially next time around it's gonna
be Wednesday if you're still in your
home locked up you can't go out other
than the by maybe food and grew and
drugs or whatever well then then you'll
probably tune in so we'll see you on
Wednesday and hopefully you don't catch
the virus bye-bye